i want to ask you about the circle this
is a really interesting game
uh and it's a game show but it feels
like
it is very current in that it's really
dealing with
this phenomenon of how you present
yourself on the internet
yeah you know season one was really
interesting because
people had to sort of wrap their mind
around the idea of being quarantined in
an apartment and
just communicating with people through
social media or
social messaging app and now season two
we're just like
yeah we got it like this is what we're
doing oh my god look at my elbows
conan what's wrong with your elbows they
look what's
send me some cocoa butter oh oh okay
i have some right here i always keep
cocoa butter here under the desk
just in case things get a little
where do you think i was going i meant
in case my elbows got dry
what are you thinking look we've come
through a circle
listen getting back to the circle
i think how would your mom react to what
we just did
there she is there she is reacting to
our little cocoa butter run
i mean it's the cutest disapproving
thing you could ever see
is it okay if i use that clip on my show
from now on just
until we run this thing out which is
just whenever something doesn't go right
whenever i say something that isn't
quite kosher i want to cut away to your
mom
looking like that absolutely she'd be so
proud and all the other caribbean
catholic moms
would feel seen as well so the circle
what i love about it is that people can
they're essentially lying about who they
are they're catfishing
you can be a catfish if you choose to
yeah um or you can be yourself
which is so fascinating because we all
have to sort of deal with social media
even if we don't want to it's just a
part of our lives and so
it's always an interesting conversation
what your profile and profile pictures
say about you
how people receive you how tone is
really lost in text
but with that you know they use the word
popular because it is a popularity game
but it's sort of like what makes you
popular right
oh my goodness what was that i heard a
beep and a door open
that was my front door i think it was
just a wind
i don't think so the wind wouldn't make
it go beep beep
i think you have a robot burglar that's
my assumption right now
we'll let that go that's my circle
messaging app but um
yeah i mean it it's such a fascinating
watch and it's really entertaining as
well because
you know the casting is so good it
really is just like
you know a motley crew and um yeah and
the reason why
people catfish sometimes is so
sad it's so interesting because you know
a lot of people will say
well somebody doesn't want to really get
to know an older person
and i'm in my 50s so i'm going to play a
younger person because that's who's on
social media
right and by the end of it people are
like i wish i have got
like just really got to know you the
real you um
you know some people are like nobody
wants to talk to a
a person my size so i'm going to be a
skinny person and that's just so sad and
so i think the takeaway is
you know you are always enough yeah
whatever you feel like presenting you
know um
to the world on social media um take
ownership
be kind and and you are enough
to put this on a magnet
[Laughter]
no one made noise like that in my church